I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi, how you doing?
I'm doing pretty good.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后花絮和许多闺蜜故事，更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是Office Ladies 6.0。嗨，最近怎么样？我过得还不错。
I was doing pretty good and then I just got a text and now I'm in grumps.
Oh, can I tell you what it is?
Yeah. Because this is actually an opportunity for me to set something straight.
Okay. Am I coming in hot?
You're coming in a little spicy. What you got?
All right, right before we got on Mike, I'm checking my phone, and my mom has sent me this text.
And she sent me this screenshot where she's like, facts about famous actresses.
Oh, no. I know. Don't send me that.
我本来过得挺好的，然后我刚收到了一条短信，现在我很生气。哦，能告诉我是什么事吗？可以。因为这其实是一个我澄清事实的机会。好吧。我是不是来势汹汹？你确实有点冲。你有什么料？好吧，就在我们上麦之前，我正在看手机，我妈妈给我发了这条短信。她发给我一张截图，上面写着：关于著名女演员的真相。哦，不。我知道。别发给我这个。
I found this online. Is this true? Here's the fact about me.
Jenna Fisher still owns the engagement ring.
Her co-star John Cresensky gave her on the office,
and she has even been seen wearing it off screen.
Everyone, settle down.
Not true.
I do have Pam's rings,
which were, by the way, given to Pam from Jim.
我在网上看到的。这是真的吗？关于我的事实是这样的：珍娜·菲舍尔仍然保留着她的联合主演约翰·卡拉辛斯基在《办公室》里送给她的订婚戒指，甚至有人看到她在镜头外戴着它。大家，冷静点。这不是真的。我确实有潘的戒指，顺便说一句，那是吉姆送给潘的。
Right?
Yeah.
I also have Pam's purse.
I also have Pam's sweater.
I have Pam's watch.
Who gave those items to you was the problem.
Department. Phil Shea.
Phil Shea, who also gave me my cat earrings that Angela Martin wore.
对吧？是的。我还拥有潘的钱包。我还拥有潘的毛衣。我有潘的手表。是谁把这些东西给你的才是问题所在。道具部门。菲尔·谢伊。菲尔·谢伊，他还给了我安吉拉·马丁戴过的猫咪耳环。
Yes. Phil Shea put together a wonderful package when the show ended.
Of all of these items, Pam's purse, I remember he gave John the satchel that Jim always carried.
The cross body bag. So he collected little items for us.
He gave me Dwight and Angela's wedding program. Yes. You have the ring.
that Dwight gives Angela. Right. Yes. So yes, I have this ring. I have it along with many other items that I have. There's nothing attached to it other than memorabilia from a show you were on that you loved. Correct. Correct. And you know what ring I wear is my actual wedding ring from my actual real life husband of 16 years who I love with all my heart. Yes. Yes. Sometimes it's just so hard, lady. The internet's a
whack-a-doodle place. It is. And I've told you my crazy story. Oh, my gosh. You guys,
this is crazy. This is crazy. Sam, you don't know this story, but it's bonkers. You got to hear this.
I told Jenna this the other day. Okay. So you guys know, I did a charity tennis match with Steve Correll,
是的。节目结束时，菲尔·谢伊准备了一个精彩的包裹。在所有这些物品中，潘的钱包，我记得他给了约翰一个吉姆总是背的斜挎包。那个单肩包。所以他为我们收集了小物件。他给了我德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼节目单。是的。你有德怀特给安吉拉的戒指。对。是的。所以是的，我有这枚戒指。我和我拥有的许多其他物品放在一起。除了你深爱过的一部剧的纪念品之外，它没有任何别的意义。没错。没错。你知道我戴的是什么戒指吗？是我和我结婚16年的真人的真老公的真正的结婚戒指，我全心全意地爱着他。没错。没错。有时候事情就是这么艰难，女士们。互联网真是一个稀奇古怪的地方。确实。而且我跟你讲过我那个疯狂的故事。哦，天哪。你们，这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。萨姆，你不知道这个故事，但它太离谱了。你得听听这个。我前几天把这个告诉珍娜了。好吧。所以你们知道，我和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起参加了一场慈善网球赛，
his wife, Nancy, and Raine Wilson. And it was all to go towards supporting Rain's amazing charity,
Lidee, Haiti. And after the tennis match, there was like a little meat and greet.
and this man was there and he had sort of like an assistant person with him.
He was lovely, by the way.
But you could tell he was very excited that he had found different little pieces of trivia about us online.
Again, it's the trivia.
It's the trivia, which is probably just an AI bot that gets half the information, right?
And then the rest is wrong.
他的妻子南茜，还有雷恩·威尔逊。这一切都是为了支持雷恩的精彩慈善机构——海地Lidee。网球赛结束后，有一个小型见面会，有一个男士也在场，他身边好像还跟着一个助理似的人。顺便说一句，他人很好。但你能看出他非常兴奋，因为他在网上找到了关于我们的各种小八卦。又是八卦。又是八卦，这可能只是一个AI机器人，只获取了一半的信息，对的，其余的都是错的。
So like, I forget the information that he knew about Steve.
It was something like, oh, maybe his parents, how they met or something.
I can't remember, right?
And Steve was like, oh, yeah, that's correct.
Because probably he talked about it in an interview somewhere, right?
And then he turns to me and he goes, Angela, your family collects body parts?
Exactly.
So I started laughing like that.
所以，比如，我忘了关于史蒂夫的那个信息是什么了。好像是，哦，也许是他的父母，他们是怎么认识的之类的。我不记得了，对吧？然后史蒂夫说，哦，对，没错。因为他可能在某个采访中提到过，对吧？然后他转过身对我说，安吉拉，你们家收集身体部位吗？没错。所以我当时就笑得这样。
I said, what?
I thought it was a joke.
I thought I was getting punked somehow.
I was like, what?
And then Steve literally was taking a sip of water and almost spit it all over me.
He started laughing so hard.
And we looked at each other and I was like, what are you talking?
about. He turns to his assistant like, and she goes, the foot. And he goes, there was a foot
我说，什么？我以为是个玩笑。我以为自己被整蛊了。我当时想，什么？然后史蒂夫正喝着水，差点全喷到我身上。他笑得前俯后仰。我们对视了一眼，我当时想，你在说什么。他转向他的助理说，然后助理说，那只脚。然后他说，有一只脚
that you guys had. Like you, like a foot. I was like, oh my gosh. I said, you guys, you know how at
Halloween you can go into Spencer's gifts in the mall. Yeah, get like a foot that hangs out of the trunk.
Get a foot that hangs out of the trunk. Ha, ha, ha. My mom got one of those. And instead of
hanging it out of the trunk of the car, she put it by the bathroom.
room door by our back door as like a prank. And we all were like,
and we're like, mom. And it was a story I told where they were like,
who's the prankster in your family? I'm like, my mom is kind of a prankster. I told this one
story. I'm like, oh my gosh, are there people somewhere in the world that think I have like
你们曾经有过。就像你，就像一只脚。我当时想，哦，天哪。我说，你们知道万圣节时你可以去商场里的Spencer's礼品店。对，买一只挂在后备箱外面的脚。买一只挂在后备箱外面的脚。哈哈哈哈。我妈妈就买了一个。她没有把它挂在汽车后备箱外面，而是把它放在浴室门边，在我们的后门旁边，作为一个恶作剧。然后我们都觉得，我们说，妈。这是一个我讲过的故事，当时他们问，谁是你家里最爱恶作剧的人？我说，我妈妈有点像个爱恶作剧的人。我讲了这么一个故事。我说，哦，天哪，世界上某处会不会有人以为我有一个
a foot in a jar that we collect this crap? But now all I can think about is, oh my God,
now I've told the story here. Now AI is going to take this. This is going to go into a
transcript. The story is out there in a second way. But I'm hoping.
I want to set the record straight.
AI, if you're listening,
will you please stop telling this story about me?
Because I've read this multiple times over the years
ever since I was on a talk show,
泡在罐子里的脚，我们还收集这种垃圾？但现在我脑子里想的全是，哦，天哪，现在我把这个故事讲到这里了。现在人工智能要把它抓取走了。这将变成一份文字记录。这个故事以第二种方式流传出去了。但我希望。我想澄清事实。人工智能，如果你在听，请你停止讲述这个关于我的故事好吗？因为自从我上脱口秀节目以来，多年里我已经读到过好多次了，
and I gave a list of things that I kept from the show,
and this was one of the things in the list.
And somehow the telephone game has turned this into something else.
Here's the thing I'm going to say,
if you're going to have an AI bot, get something horribly wrong.
Maybe the jewelry tidbit is better than the, like, collects body part.
Can we just say that?
It does make me feel a little better.
我列出了一份我从剧组留下的物品清单，这就是清单中的一项。不知怎么的，传话游戏把这变成了别的东西。我要说的是，如果你非要用人工智能机器人，那就弄个错得离谱的吧。也许珠宝的八卦比收集身体部位要好一点。我们能这么说吗？这确实让我感觉好受了一点。
I haven't told my mom the story, you guys, but I feel like I need to.
Because I feel like there's going to be someone at church that comes up to her.
It's like, Birdie, what's up with you?
What's with the feet?
Well, Angela, I do appreciate you telling that story because I had the grumps and now I'm laughing.
So thank you.
So you're welcome.
And I'm actually really excited about our episode today.
我还没把这个故事告诉妈妈，伙计们，但我觉得我需要告诉她。因为我觉得教堂里会有人走过去跟她说。伯蒂，你这是怎么回事？那些脚是怎么回事？好吧，安吉拉，我真的很感激你讲那个故事，因为我之前很不高兴，现在我在笑了。所以谢谢你。不客气。其实我对我们今天的节目非常兴奋。
I'm happy to be here.
we get to talk with Calvin Tenor who played Glenn in the warehouse.
You guys, he is just an absolute joyful person, and I really can't wait for you all to get
to know him better.
And I've been reunited with him now over the last few years working on the AT&T commercial
campaign.
So I'm just excited I get to see him again today because he just is wonderful.
Same.
我很高兴来到这里。我们能和在仓库里扮演格伦的卡尔文·特纳聊天了。伙计们，他真的是一个充满欢乐的人，我真的迫不及待想让你们更好地了解他。过去几年里，我在拍摄AT&T广告时又和他重聚了。所以我很高兴今天能再见到他，因为他真的很棒。我也是。
Jenna and I were really fortunate.
We got to hang out and spend a lot of time with him over the past couple of years between
fan conventions and AT&T, and you're going to see why we love them. You just wait.
But let's start with our fan chit-chat question of the week. This is coming from Emily A.
in Tucson, Arizona. Hi, Angela and Jenna. This is Emily. I live in Tucson, Arizona, and I really enjoy your
podcast. Thank you so much for all that you do. My Friday chit-chat question is, I'm taking a poll
on the use of a top sheet on the bed.
All of my children, even though I raised them using a top sheet, would just kick them to the end of the bed,
珍娜和我都非常幸运。在过去的几年里，我们在粉丝见面会和AT&T活动之间，和她一起出去玩了很长时间，你们会明白我们为什么爱他。你们就等着瞧吧。但让我们从本周的粉丝闲聊问题开始。这是来自亚利桑那州图森市的艾米丽·A提出的。嗨，安吉拉和珍娜。我是艾米丽。我住在亚利桑那州图森市，我真的很喜欢你们的播客。非常感谢你们所做的一切。我周五的闲聊问题是，我正在做一个关于在床上是否使用床单（top sheet）的调查。我所有的孩子，尽管我抚养他们时让他们用了床单，但他们总是把床单踢到床尾，
even though I very crankily explained that the comforter and bed spread did not get washed
that frequently.
So it seems a younger generation thing that there's no top sheet.
And I just wondered if you guys use a top sheet.
If you have your kids use a top sheet and just what is the deal with not using a top sheet?
Thank you.
And I look forward to your opinion on the matter.
Emily, everything about that message is wonderful.
尽管我很生气地解释说羽绒被和床罩没有洗得那么频繁。所以没有床单似乎是年轻一代的一大特点。我只是想知道你们用不用床单？你们会让孩子们用床单吗？不用床单到底是怎么回事？谢谢。我期待听到你们对这件事的看法。艾米丽，那条信息的一切都很棒。
The journey I went on listening to that message, I have so many strong feelings about it that I didn't even realize I knew I had.
Well, you know, she also wrote us a letter that went with this audio clip, and I'd like you to know if she seems weary at all about this top sheet issue, she's talking about her kids. She raised 10. 10 kids.
Yeah. So this is 10 beds of top sheets not being used. Yeah. Okay. I just want to give it some perspective.
Well, what are your thoughts, lady? How do you feel about a top sheet? Again, it's something that I didn't know I had an opinion on, but I actually do.
I have a very strong opinion on it.
I'm all for a top sheet.
Same.
I love a top sheet.
我听那条信息时的心路历程，我对它有那么多强烈的情感，甚至连我自己都没意识到我居然有这些情感。嗯，你知道的，她还给我们写了一封信，随这个音频片段一起发来的，我想让你知道，如果她对这个床单问题表现出任何疲惫的话，她是在谈论她的孩子。她抚养了10个。10个孩子。是的。所以这是10张床不使用床单。是的。好吧。我只是想从宏观角度来看待它。好吧，女士，你有什么想法？你对床单有什么看法？再次说明，这是一件我以前不知道自己有看法的事情，但我确实有。我对此有非常强烈的看法。我完全支持用床单。我也是。我喜欢床单。
And here's the thing.
I grew up with the top sheet.
And then, of course, on Isabel's bed, I had a top sheet, you know, pull back the blanket in her top sheet, crawl in, tuck her in, you know, bedtime story.
And then when Josh and I got married and we blended our families and the boys shared a room and they had bunk beds.
And I would make their bed and I'd put a top sheet on.
Sure.
Under the comforter.
And then I would go in to say good night to them and they would either be lying on top of the top sheet and have not to have pulled it back.
事情是这样的。我是在铺床单的环境中长大的。然后，当然，在伊莎贝尔的床上，我给她用床单，你知道的，掀开她床单上的毯子，爬进去，给她掖好被子，你知道的，讲睡前故事。然后当乔伊和我结婚后，我们重组了家庭，男孩们合住一个房间，他们睡双层床。我会给他们铺床，放上一张床单。当然。在羽绒被下面。然后我会进去跟他们说晚安，他们要么躺在床单上面，根本没有把它掀开。
Or the next morning I would find the top sheet completely rolled in a ball at the foot of the bed.
Just like Emily is saying.
And this cycle went over and over and I would be like, guys, the top sheet.
And they'd be like, I don't really need it.
I don't really want it.
This was like a battle.
Josh was like, let it go.
或者第二天早上我发现床单完全揉成一个球塞在床尾。就像艾米丽说的那样。就像艾米丽说的那样。这个循环周而复始，我会说，伙计们，床单。他们会说，我真的不需要它。我真的不想要它。这就像是一场战斗。乔伊说，算了吧。
Let this one go.
And so now it's like I do have a top sheet on their beds.
I still put it on.
Sometimes they're under it.
Sometimes they're on top of it.
Sometimes it's at the foot of the bed.
I've let it go, but I still put it on the bed.
I feel strongly about a top sheet for all the reasons Emily is saying, which is that I don't wash
随他们去吧。所以现在的情况是，我确实在他们的床上铺了床单。我还是会铺。有时候他们在床单下面。有时候他们在床单上面。有时候它在床尾。我不管了，但我还是会把它铺在床上。出于艾米丽所说的所有原因，我对床单有着强烈的执念，那就是我不洗
the comforter cover.
Yes.
But I'll wash the sheet.
That's what the top sheet is for that.
It's the purpose of it.
Exactly.
The comfort or cover takes a lot more time.
to wash, to dry, so you do that every once in a while.
羽绒被套。是的。但我会洗床单。床单就是为此而准备的。这就是它的目的。没错。羽绒被套需要花更多的时间来清洗、烘干，所以你偶尔才洗一次。
But to sheets, you wash more regularly.
Well, I think she's onto something, because I do think this is a trend where the younger
generation is abandoning the top sheet.
Because it's too much work.
Well, I don't even know, but I ordered.
I think it might be a classic case of top sheets in this economy.
Like, this strikes me as one of those.
But they come together.
但是床单，你洗得更勤。嗯，我觉得她确实说到了点子上，因为我确实认为这是一个趋势，年轻一代正在抛弃床单。因为太麻烦了。好吧，我甚至不知道，但我订购了。我想这可能是当今经济形势下床单问题的一个经典案例。这让我想起了那种类型的文章。
But this strikes me as one of those articles where it's like, are millennials ruining the diamond
business?
And you're like, who's buying diamonds?
No, I disagree.
Who author has top sheet money in this economy?
Hold up.
Sheet money.
Top sheet money.
但这让我想起了那种文章，就像是，千禧一代正在毁掉钻石行业吗？你会想，谁在买钻石呢？不，我不同意。在这个经济形势下，哪个作者有闲钱买床单？等等。床单钱。床单钱。
They come together in a sheet set.
And you can buy them separately, I guess.
But like they come in a bundle except, and this is my point, because I think maybe people are wanting
to drop the top sheet, is that I went to buy like a new comforter and sheets for my daughter's
bed.
And when they arrived, there was no top sheet.
It was just a fitted sheet.
And then this cover that I put on her comforter.
它们是成套床单里的。我想你可以分开买，我猜。但它们是一起打包出售的，除了——这就是我的重点，因为我觉得可能人们想要抛弃床单——那就是我去为我女儿的床买一套新的羽绒被和床单。当它们送到时，里面没有床单。只有床笠。然后是我套在她羽绒被上的这个被套。
and I was grumpy about it because now I have to wash it all the time.
And now I have to wrestle her duvet back into this top sheet slash comforter cover.
You know what's happened?
What?
The comforter cover people have come for the top sheet.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
That's what's happened.
我对这件事很不满，因为现在我必须一直洗它。现在我必须把她的被芯塞回这个床单兼羽绒被套里。你知道发生了什么吗？什么？羽绒被套制造商对床单下手了。哦，天哪。就是这样。就是这么回事。
We just cracked a case mom, detective, hi-fi.
Yes.
All right.
Emily, that got us going.
Sam, I'm sorry, top sheet or no for you.
No.
No, no.
No, no, top sheet.
我们刚刚侦破了一起案件，妈妈，侦探，hi-fi。是的。好吧，艾米丽，这让我们聊嗨了。萨姆，对你来说抱歉，到底用不用床单？不用。不，不。不，不用床单。
I can't afford a top sheet.
I'm not.
You can't afford a top sheet.
I don't have a fainting couch in my living room.
Oh my gosh.
Glass chandelier.
This is ridiculous.
You go to Target and you get a fitted sheet, a top sheet, and two pillowcases in a bundle.
我买不起床单。我不是... 你买不起床单。我客厅里可没有贵妃椅。天哪。水晶吊灯。这太荒谬了。你去塔吉特百货，就能买到一个包含床笠、床单和两个枕套的套装。
Well, listen, we're not going to provide you with a top sheet today, but speaking of bedding,
we've got a little something for you because your birthday was last week, which, although, as you all are listening to this last month, we celebrate.
celebrated off mic because we weren't recording that day.
But we have a late breaking gift that has come in.
You might ready for you to have it.
You might remember when you opened your gifts from us.
I do remember.
We said there was something coming.
好吧，听着，我们今天可不会给你提供床单，不过说到寝具，我们为你准备了一点小礼物，因为你上周过生日——尽管，正如大家在上个月听到这个节目时所知，我们是在没有录音的那天私下庆祝的。但我们收到了一个迟来的礼物。你可能... 准备好接收它了。你可能还记得你打开我们送的礼物的时候。我确实记得。我们说过还有东西要来。
Now I wish we would have bought him a dang top sheet to go with it though.
All right, here, I'm going to go grab it.
Come on in here, Sam.
Okay.
I love the bag.
Will you describe it?
It's a Star Wars bag.
specifically the original series Star Wars.
现在我倒希望我们当时给他买条该死的床单配着了。好吧，我去拿一下。快进来，山姆。好的。我喜欢这个包。你能描述一下吗？这是一个《星球大战》的包，具体来说是原版三部曲的《星球大战》。
Oh my God, this is huge.
All right.
Just describe it.
You have to describe it.
It is an entire me-sized blanket of my dog ramen.
Oh, I love it.
It's a 50 by 60 blanket of your dog's face.
This is bigger than you are.
天哪，这太大了。好吧。你描述一下。你必须描述一下。这是一条我整个人大小的毯子，上面印着我的狗拉面。哦，我太喜欢了。这是一条50乘60英寸印着你狗狗脸的毯子。这比你还要大呢。
It is.
Oh, thank you so much.
We kind of thought, like, what does Sam love more than anything?
It's ramen.
And naps with ramen.
Yeah, and naps with ramen.
And now you can snuggle ramen in ramen.
Yeah, thank you.
确实。哦，非常感谢。我们当时想，山姆最喜欢什么？是拉面。还有和拉面一起小睡。是的，还有和拉面一起小睡。现在你可以在拉面里抱着拉面了。是的，谢谢。
All right.
Well, listen, happy birthday, Sam.
We love you.
We are going to take a break.
And when we come back, we are going to chat with Calvin Tenner, who played Glenn from the warehouse.
The Second World War is the largest event in human history.
A 20-part series with Tom Hanks.
No part of the globe was untouched.
好吧。听着，生日快乐，山姆。我们爱你。我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将与卡尔文·特纳聊聊，他在剧中饰演仓库里的格伦。第二次世界大战是人类历史上规模最大的事件。由汤姆·汉克斯主持的20集系列纪录片。地球上没有任何一个角落未受影响。
No life unchanged.
Experience the ultimate account of World War II.
Every single person had a story.
These are the stories that make us who we are.
Listen to World War II with Tom Hanks on Apple, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hello.
Hi, everybody.
We have someone pretty special in the studio with us today.
没有任何生活不曾改变。体验关于二战的终极记述。每个人都有自己的故事。正是这些故事塑造了我们。在Apple、Spotify或你获取播客的任何地方收听汤姆·汉克斯主持的《第二次世界大战》。你好。大家好。今天我们的录音室里来了一位非常特别的人。
It is Calvin Tenor.
Woo-hoo!
Hey, everyone.
Welcome to Office Ladies.
It's nice to be here.
Thank you, ladies, for having me.
You guys might know him as Glenn, but we love him as Calvin.
Yes.
他就是卡尔文·特纳。呜呼！大家好。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。很高兴来到这里。谢谢女士们邀请我。大家可能知道他是格伦，但我们更喜欢叫他卡尔文。是的。
And I also had two other names tags on the show, which was Calvin and Lester.
That's right.
That's a little office trivia.
I feel like they played this trivia game at bars and stuff, and that's a good one.
Yeah.
So who did you start as Lester and then Calvin and then
而且我在节目中还有其他两个名字标签，分别是卡尔文和莱斯特。没错。这是一个办公室冷知识。我觉得他们会在酒吧之类的地方玩这种冷知识游戏，这是一个很好的题目。是的。是的。是的。所以你一开始演的是莱斯特，然后是卡尔文，然后是
Glenn? Or were you Glenn and then Calvin at one point again? No, it was Lester first than Calvin,
then Glenn. Okay. Which was crazy. I was like another name tag? I was like, yes.
No one's keeping track. Well, I did see in the episode the cover up that Daryl calls you Glenn.
Correct. So your name is officially said in the series as Glenn. Correct. Well, we always like to start
by asking people the same question. Okay.
Which is, how did you get your job on the office? And I read a tidbit that said it might have had something to do with the fact that you were certified to use a forklift in real life.
Correct.
Okay. Tell us this story. Yeah.
格伦？还是说你是格伦，然后又变成了卡尔文？不，先是莱斯特，然后是卡尔文，最后是格伦。好吧。这太疯狂了。我当时想：又有一个名牌？我心想，好吧。根本没人记这个。不过，我在“掩盖”那一集里确实看到达里尔叫你格伦。没错。所以你在剧中的名字官方确定是格伦。没错。好吧，我们总是喜欢用同一个问题来开始采访。好的。那就是，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？我读到过一个小花絮，说这可能与你在现实生活中拥有叉车操作证书有关。没错。好吧。给我们讲讲这个故事。Yeah。
So I was pretty much a background actor on the office, as you know. But the reason how I got there was because I had a certification to drive a forklift and stuff like that. So my background, I was a supervisor at a courtebrose.
plan in San Jose, California. And one morning I told my boss, I'm putting in my two weeks
notice. And that kind of ended right there that day because he was kind of mad at me. You said,
you can leave now. And I was like, ooh, okay. Now, had you gotten the background job in the office
when you gave the two weeks notice? I was still in the Bay Area at this time. Okay. And then what made
you want to get into putting yourself out there for acting at all? So after I moved to L.A.,
I was in 24-hour fitness.
Okay.
所以，如你所知，我基本上是《办公室》里的背景演员。但我之所以能去那里，是因为我有开叉车之类的证书。我的背景是，我是加利福尼亚州圣何塞一家Costco配送中心的监督员。一天早晨，我告诉我的老板，我要提交两周的辞职通知。然后那天事情就在那里结束了，因为他有点生我的气。你说，你现在就可以走了。我当时想，噢，好吧。那么，当你递交两周辞职通知时，你已经拿到《办公室》的背景演员工作了吗？我当时还在湾区。好吧。那是什么让你想要涉足演艺事业的呢？所以在我搬到洛杉矶后，我在24小时健身房。好的。
And a guy told me, he was like, you should be on TV.
You were just working out at the gym.
And the guy approached me and said, you should be on TV.
And I was like, oh, okay, so how do you do that?
So I just did some research, and that's how I became on the show.
This is like an old Hollywood lore story where it's like Greta Garbo's like somewhere and they're like, you should be in the movie.
Yeah.
I call it right place at the right time.
有个家伙对我说，你应该去电视上露脸。你当时只是在健身房锻炼。那个人走过来对我说，你应该上电视。我当时想，哦，好吧，那怎么做呢？所以我做了一些研究，这就是我如何参与到这部剧中的。这就像是一个老好莱坞的传奇故事，就像葛丽泰·嘉宝在某个地方，然后别人对她说，你应该去拍电影。是的。我称之为在对的时间出现在对的地点。
Well, was the office your first job then in the entertainment industry?
The office was actually my third.
Okay.
What was your first job?
I was doing other background stuff.
So it was my first official booking.
Was the office?
Yes, it was the office.
好吧，《办公室》是你进入娱乐行业的的第一份工作吗？《办公室》其实是我的第三份。好吧。你的第一份工作是什么？我在做其他背景工作。所以我的第一份正式签约工作是《办公室》？是的，是《办公室》。
Wow.
Yes.
That's what I said.
Wow.
I mean, had you seen the show before?
Never seen the show.
Okay.
So will you share with us, like, what was your first day like on set?
哇。是的。我当时就这么说，哇。我的意思是，你以前看过这部剧吗？从来没看过这部剧。好吧。那你能不能跟我们分享一下，你在片场的第一天是什么样的？
What episode was it?
Will you paint us a picture?
Okay.
I'm going to take you guys way back.
All right.
So I remember back in, this is back in 2008, me and my wife were planning to get married.
So what happened was I already got married in Florida.
那是哪一集？你能给我们描绘一下吗？好的。我要把你们带回很久以前。好的。好吧。我记得在2008年，我和我妻子正计划结婚。所以发生的事情是，我已经去佛罗里达结过婚了。
So we had booked our tickets.
So I was called to work on an episode.
And I told them, I said, well, I leave to go to Florida.
night because I'm getting married. I said, but you know what? I'm going to postpone that and just
come shoot the episode. You postponed your wedding to come shoot the episode? Yes, yeah. So I postponed
it and I went shot the episode and I was still background at this time on the show. And once we shot,
I caught a red eye to Florida. And the day we got married was we got married 8-8 at 808,
Oh.
所以我们已经订好了机票。然后我被叫去拍一集。我告诉他们，我说，嗯，我今晚就要去佛罗里达，因为我要结婚了。我说，但你知道吗？我要把婚礼推迟，来拍这一集。你为了拍这一集把婚礼推迟了？对，是的。所以我推迟了婚礼，去拍了那一集，当时我还在剧中演背景演员。拍完之后，我赶了一趟红眼航班去佛罗里达。我们结婚的日子是8月8日8点08分，哦。
2008.
So the next day, I get a call from Rain Wilson,
and he said, we put together a little care package for you for your wedding.
And I was like, what?
Like, I was very ecstatic.
I was like, you kidding me.
Right?
So I want to say, they sent me like three grand.
2008年。所以第二天，我接到了雷恩·威尔逊的电话，他说，我们为你准备了一个小护理包作为结婚礼物。我当时想，什么？就像，我非常狂喜。我心想，你在开玩笑吧。对吧？所以我想说，他们给我寄了大约三千块。
What?
Exactly.
You know what?
I actually am now remembering.
You remember?
Here's the thing.
This is very early on.
什么？没错。你知道吗？你知道吗？我实际上现在想起来了。你记起来了？事情是这样的。这是非常早期的时候。
I remember Rain was like, hey, you guys, one of the warehouse workers is getting married.
And now that you're saying this, I remember we all took up, like everyone chipped in, cast and crew.
Yes.
Correct.
Cast and crew.
Well, I remember we used to do that sometimes.
我记得雷恩当时说，嘿，大家，其中一个仓库工人要结婚了。现在你这么一说，我记得我们大家都出钱了，演员和剧组所有人都凑钱了。是的。没错。是的。没错。演员和剧组。好吧，我记得我们以前有时会那样做。
We did.
Actually, we did it quite often from different occasions in people's lives.
Graduations, baby showers, things like that.
We would all chip in as cast and crew.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
And Rain, I never knew how.
that got to you. Yes. That is wonderful. Rain sent that to me. And I was in tears in Florida on the beach
我们确实这样做过。事实上，我们在人们生活中的不同场合经常这样做。毕业典礼、迎婴派对之类的事情。我们演员和剧组都会一起凑钱。是的。哦，天哪。雷恩，我从不知道那是怎么送到你手里的。是的。太棒了。雷恩把那个寄给了我。我在佛罗里达的海滩上流下了眼泪
because I didn't know that everyone cared like that. You know? So we got married when me and my wife came
back. I remember we went up to the office, went up to the set, and you guys were at lunchtime. And
that's when I introduced my wife to everyone. I brought like a chocolate basket with the chocolate
fruit. Yeah. And I introduced my wife. And then we thanked you guys.
for that gift.
And she was so embarrassed.
Because I had her standing next to me,
and I had to introduce her as my wife.
因为我不知道每个人都在乎这些。你知道吗？所以我们结婚后，我和妻子回来了。我记得我们去了办公室，去了片场，你们当时正在吃午休。就在那时，我把我的妻子介绍给了每个人。我带了一个巧克力篮子，里面有巧克力水果。是的。我把我的妻子介绍了大家。然后我们向你们表达了对那份礼物的感谢。她当时超级尴尬。因为我让她站在我旁边，我不得不把她介绍为我的妻子。
It was so fun.
It was amazing.
And I think at that point in time,
some of the writers didn't get a chance to add to it.
Yeah, the writers hadn't shipped in.
Yeah.
So I get a call maybe a week later,
and they wrote me in an episode.
太有趣了。太棒了。我想当时有些编剧还没有机会参与进来。是的，编剧们还没来得及凑钱。所以我大约一周后接到了电话，他们把我写进了一集里。
So I was like, wait a minute.
Is this the Hollywood dream about to come true?
Really?
This is something really special about the office.
I feel like it is a really special, you know,
Jen and I talk about it for years now on this podcast,
that it was a really special group of people.
And when you became a part of the office family,
所以我当时想，等一下。难道这就是好莱坞梦想即将成真吗？真的吗？关于《办公室》，确实有些非常特别的事情。我觉得这是一个非常特别的群体，詹和我在这档播客里谈论了好几年，它是一个非常特别的群体。当你成为《办公室》大家庭的一部分时，
you were part of the office family.
And we wanted to celebrate your accomplishments.
We wanted to be with you if you were in hard times,
you know, because there are people cast and crew
who went through hard times,
and we rallied around them as well, you know, financially, emotionally.
It was just a special place to work.
Yes, it was amazing.
你就是《办公室》大家庭的一员。我们想庆祝你的成就。如果你遇到困难，我们希望和你站在一起，你知道的，因为剧组里有些演员和工作人员经历过困难时期，我们也团结在他们周围，给予他们经济上和情感上的支持。这真是一个特别的工作场所。是的，太棒了。
Positive.
Yes.
Everyone is so amazing on that show.
Well, when you first got your job and you're like, okay, I'm going to be a background
player on this show, first of all, did you know that would recur?
Did they say you might be back?
Okay, so you're like, this is a one-off that now you are getting a gift for your wedding
绝对的。是的。是的。那部剧里的每个人都太棒了。好吧，当你刚得到这份工作，心里想，好吧，我要在这部剧里当个背景演员，首先，你知道这会是常驻角色吗？他们说过你可能会回来吗？好吧，所以你觉得这是一次性的客串，而现在你却为你的婚礼收到了礼物
and you're a part of it
and they're writing you in more episodes.
Exactly. Exactly.
They were like, you know,
they could keep asking you to come back.
Okay.
So I was like, okay.
And in my head, as long as I keep doing great work,
而你是其中的一部分，他们在更多的剧集中把你写了进去。完全正确。完全正确。他们就像是，你知道的，他们会一直让你回来。好吧。所以我就想，好吧。在我的脑海里，只要我一直表现出色，
they'll ask me to come back.
So that's what kept happening.
They asked me to come back.
Then they asked me to come back again.
I didn't know that it was going to be a reoccurring part.
I just thought it was like a one and done.
Yeah.
他们就会让我回来。这就是一直发生的事情。他们让我回来。然后他们又让我回来。我不知道这会是一个常驻角色。我只是以为这是一次性的。是的。是的。
Until my agent had called me,
hey, they want you to come back.
Hey, they want you to come back again.
Well, in the warehouse, you're heavily featured.
I mean, I was kind of going through your IMDB list of episodes.
There's 16.
Yes.
So then I just started poking around.
直到我的经纪人打电话给我，嘿，他们想让你回来。嘿，他们想让你再次回来。在仓库里，你的戏份很重。我的意思是，我刚才大致浏览了你的IMDB剧集列表。有16集。所以我就开始四处查看。
And there were moments that I had forgotten about.
And I have to ask you about one.
Okay.
So obviously you have some great scenes between Glenn and Daryl.
But I want to ask you about Fun Run Part 2.
Michael crosses the finish line finally.
and he pukes, and you're the person standing right next to him.
And, I mean, I know that's like this gag that Steve Carell had to do, you know,
有些时刻我都忘了。我得问你一个。好吧。很明显，格伦和达里尔之间有一些很棒的对手戏。但我想问你关于“欢乐跑 第二部分”的事。迈克尔终于冲过了终点线，他吐了，而你就是站在他旁边的那个人。我的意思是，我知道那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔必须做的一个笑料，你知道的，
like to make that all happen.
But you're like the closest person to him.
And I just, I have to know, like, what was that like?
Do you have like a vivid memory of like times when you were on said that you're like,
I will never forget that?
Yes, the fun run was a great episode.
You know, just to be out there on the streets, just running.
cut, and then you go around the corner, run again, cut.
就像把这一切都实现一样。但你是离他最近的人。我只是，我必须知道，那是什么感觉？你对在片场的时光有什么生动的记忆，让你觉得，我永远不会忘？是的，欢乐跑是一集很棒的节目。你知道，就是在街上，一直跑。喊停，然后你绕过街角，再跑，喊停。
It didn't meet up at the park, cut.
But that was my first time just watching someone puke on camera constantly.
So I thought that was pretty funny.
And you didn't break?
No, no, no.
Did you ever break in a scene?
Did I ever?
You know what?
在公园汇合，喊停。但那是我第一次亲眼看到有人在镜头前不停地呕吐。所以我认为这挺搞笑的。你没有笑场？没有，没有，没有。你在片场笑场过吗？我有吗？你知道吗？
At that point in time, I was like, I want to keep coming back, so no.
Right, right.
I'm not going to be the one.
Yeah.
I have to ask, so you had never seen the show,
and now you're on the show.
Like, what was your first impression
of this crazy show
在那时，我想的是，我还想继续回来，所以没有。对，对。我可不是那种人。Yeah. 我不得不问，你以前从没看过这部剧，而现在你加入了这部剧。那么，对于你现在身处其中的这部疯狂的剧集，你的第一印象是什么
that you were now on?
Did anyone explain, like,
this is a documentary or anything?
No.
Okay.
No, I had to start watching it for myself.
Uh-huh.
And then, I don't know if you ladies knew it,
有人解释过，比如这是纪录片之类的吗？没有。好吧。不，我不得不自己开始看。嗯哼。然后，我不知道你们这些女士知不知道，
but I always stood on set
and watched you all do your thing.
So it was like acting class for me,
you know,
just to watch you all go off of each other.
And you guys were able to add certain things into it, too.
And it was just so crazy to me because I thought you had to be on script,
but some of it was off script as well.
我总是站在片场看你们表演。所以对我来说就像是表演课，你知道的，看着你们彼此接梗。而且你们还能在其中加入一些特定的东西。这对我来说太疯狂了，因为我以为必须按剧本演，但其中有一些也是即兴的。
So I was like, oh, this is interesting.
Like, hey, I want to do this.
And so when we were in the warehouse, you were just taking your like mental notes, mental notes.
It was just spinning, spinning and spinning.
My head was just spinning.
I was like, oh, my God.
So what happens when they're like, okay, we're going to give you lines?
Because you started off background.
所以我就想，哦，这太有趣了。就像，嘿，我也想这么做。所以当我们在仓库里时，你只是在做你的心理笔记，心理笔记。它一直在脑海里旋转，旋转，旋转。我的脑子一直在转。我就想，哦，天哪。那么，当他们说，好吧，我们要给你台词时，会发生什么？因为你一开始是演背景龙套的。
Correct.
So now, do you remember when they're like, we want, we have some words for you.
I remember.
Because, you know, Creed started off as background.
Exactly.
And then all of a sudden they were like, had this huge scene.
Here's a scene.
没错。没错。那么，你还记得他们说，我们要，我们有一些台词给你的时候吗？我记得。因为，你知道的，克里德一开始也是演背景的。没错。然后突然他们就像是，有了这么大的一场戏。这是一场戏。
Yes.
And he was like, oh, okay, I'm speaking now.
And that's what I heard.
And I was like, oh, great for Creed.
I remember the episode.
It's when Michael Scott comes down.
This is when he was talking about having a baby.
And Craig was on the couch and I was sitting on a bench.
是的。他就好像，哦，好吧，我现在要说话了。这就是我听到的。然后我就想，哦，真为克里德高兴。我记得那一集。那是迈克尔·斯科特下来的时候。这是他在谈论要个孩子的时候。克里德坐在沙发上，我坐在长凳上。
And he said something to Greg.
And I was like, I forgot the words that I said.
And when I seen that episode on TV, I was like, yeah, we got to work on some things.
Because at that point in time, I was still in the awe moment.
Yeah.
And you can see it on my face.
And I was just like, oh, my God, I'm speaking?
Really?
他对格雷格说了些什么。然后我就，我忘了我当时说的话。当我在电视上看到那一集时，我就想，是的，我们得在一些方面下功夫了。因为在那时，我仍然处于惊叹的时刻。Yeah. 你能在我的脸上看出来。我当时就想，哦，天哪，我在说话？真的吗？
And you can see that excitement on my face where it shouldn't have been that?
So I had to work on some things.
But after seeing that, I was like, okay, all right.
Well, you had a great scene in the St. Patrick's Day episode.
Yeah.
So you go up, you're in Daryl's office, right?
Because now basically he has this pitch to Joe Bennett about how to like make the whole process of like delivering paper, like better and more expedited.
And so she's like, fine.
你能在我的脸上看到那种不该有的兴奋？所以我不得不在这方面做点工作。但在看到那个之后，我就想，好吧，好吧。你在圣帕特里克节那一集里有一场很棒的戏。是的。所以你走过去，你在达里尔的办公室，对吧？因为现在基本上他向乔·贝内特提出了一个方案，关于如何让交付纸张的整个过程变得更好、更快捷。所以她说，好吧。
You know what?
You need to be up here in the main office, take Jim's office.
and then there's this great scene
where you and the other warehouse guys,
you're going to go up to Daryl's new office
and you're like, we're going to bust you out of here.
And then you kind of give them shade.
You're like, dude, did you tuck your shirt in?
你知道吗？你需要来主办公室这里，用吉姆的办公室。然后有一场精彩的戏，你和仓库的其他伙计们，你们要走到达里尔的新办公室，然后你们说，我们要把你从这里弄出去。接着你们还顺便吐槽了他一下。你们就像是，老兄，你把衬衫塞进裤子里了吗？
Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
It's like you have like some real laugh moments in that scene.
Yeah, yeah.
I always have fun working with Craig.
We kind of developed a great friendship on that show.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, I had friends in L.A.,
是的。不，不，不，不。就好像在那场戏里你有一些真正的笑点。是的，是的。和克里德合作总是很开心。我们在那部剧里建立了一种伟大的友谊。嗯哼。我的意思是，我在洛杉矶有朋友，
but I didn't really have a friend like that in L.A.
You know, we hung out outside the show.
And you still hanged.
out together and work together.
Correct.
Can you share a little bit about that with everyone?
Yeah, so after the office, Craig was, I want to say he was about to shoot Mr. Robinson
and they needed a stunt guy for him.
但我真没有在洛杉矶有过那样的一个朋友。你知道的，我们在节目之外也一起玩。你们现在还经常聚在一起，一起工作。没错。你能和大家分享一点这方面的事情吗？是的，所以在《办公室》之后，克里德，我想他是准备去拍《罗宾逊先生》，他们需要一个替身演员。而我当时没什么事可干。
And I didn't have anything going on.
So I approached the stunt coordinator and I told him, I said, hey, if you don't have Craig's
stunt double you.
I said, I'll grow my hair out, grow my beard out.
We're good to go.
He's like, come see me in two months.
when I came and seen him.
He was like, oh, okay, you fit it, let's go.
所以我找到了特技统筹，我告诉他，我说，嘿，如果你没有克里德的特技替身。我说，我会留长头发，留长胡子。我们随时准备好。他说，两个月后来找我。当我去找他时。他说，哦，好吧，你挺合适，我们走吧。
So then I started taking stun classes and stuff like that, but me and him been rocking ever since.
Yeah, you double for him a lot.
He did that commercial for AT&T where you doubled for him.
You're like covered in all the pillows.
We have to like bust through a door.
Correct.
Yeah, that was you.
So that was fun.
于是我开始上特技课之类的，但我和他从那以后就一直铁在一起。Yeah. 你经常给他做替身。他拍了那个AT&T的广告，就是你给他做替身的。你全身盖满了枕头。我们得撞门冲过去。没错。是的，那是你。所以那挺好玩的。
And then we did a whole second round of wake up with Craig and you were on set every day.
You worked all day.
We were with you all day long.
Correct.
I did the driving scene on that one, too, as well.
Yes.
Yeah.
然后我们进行了第二轮的“唤醒克里德”，你在片场待了每一天。你工作了一整天。我们和你待了一整天。没错。我在那个片子里也拍了驾驶的戏。是的。是的。Yeah.
So there's a scene where we all pull up to the new office.
You drive in as Craig.
Yeah.
They were like, yeah, just drive this Mustang like 40 miles an hour down this alley.
And then make a hard right into the parking spot.
Like, right?
And you did it.
And by the way, we're standing there.
所以有一个场景是我们把车开到新办公室。你开着车扮演克里德。Yeah. 他们就像是，把这辆野马以每小时40英里的速度开进这条小巷。然后一个急右拐停进停车位。就像这样，对吧？你做到了。顺便说一句，我们就站在那儿。
We're like, what, two feet from the car?
Yeah.
Like I'm like, Calvin, you got this?
You're like, yeah, I got it.
Got it. Great moments. Great moments.
Well, there's a scene between Glenn and Daryl and also He-Day.
And it's from a free family portrait.
Oh, my God, it's so funny. It's so funny.
我们就像是，离车两英尺远？Yeah. 就像我问，卡尔文，你行吗？你回答，行，我行。行。精彩的时刻。精彩的时刻。嗯，格伦和达里尔之间还有一场戏，还有He-Day。那是来自免费家庭肖像。哦，天哪，太搞笑了。太搞笑了。
It's so good.
I thought I could see you about to break.
I thought, now, I know you didn't, but there's a little twinkle in your eye once you know you.
And wait, can we hear it?
Yes, let's listen to it.
Let me get this straight.
You lost all of it.
all your winnings, $150,000.
太棒了。我以为我能看出你快要笑场了。我想，不，我知道你没有，但一旦你认出你来，你的眼中就会闪过一丝光芒。等等，我们能听听吗？好的，我们来听听。我把这话挑明了。你把所有的钱都输光了。你所有的积蓄，15万美元。
But to economy, but to investment.
You mean to tell me no one wanted an energy drink
for Asian homosexuals?
They did not.
And you got half a million of these?
Well, I gotta try it.
I wouldn't.
Come on, it's the hard.
但为了经济，为了投资。你的意思是告诉我没人想要一款针对亚洲同性恋的功能饮料？他们确实不要。你还有这些东西的五十万？好吧，我得试试。我才不呢。来吧，很难的。
Mmm.
Flavor is that?
Coconut penis.
Coconut is pretty subtle.
They did not.
I wouldn't.
And then also when he's like, the coconut is pretty subtle.
嗯。什么味道？椰子精液。椰子味还挺淡的。他们确实不要。他们确实不要。我才不呢。然后还有他说，椰子味还挺淡的。
It's like, that was so funny.
But that's such a great storyline that the whole warehouse wins the lottery.
Yes.
And then quits.
And quits.
And like moons everybody.
Like you guys really like come up and like dance around and be like F you everyone.
I have a question for you.
就好像，这太搞笑了。但整个仓库的人都中彩票，这真是一个极棒的故事线。没错。然后就辞职了。然后辞职。就像对所有人月光族。就像你们真的走过来，然后像跳舞一样，对所有人竖中指。我有个问题要问你。
When you guys quit, were you worried?
Were you like, no.
What is this storyline?
Exactly, exactly.
Come on.
I was like, we win the lotto and what happens after that?
I was like, oh, my God, just the end of us?
And me and He day were talking.
当你们辞职的时候，你们担心过吗？你们有没有想过，不，这到底是什么故事线？没错，没错，拜托。我当时想，我们中了彩票，之后会发生什么？我当时想，哦，天哪，难道这就是我们的结局？我和海代当时在聊这个。
I was like, hey, man, we might not come back.
So after we won a lottery, we left.
And I was just watching episodes of the office.
I was just like, oh, my God, are they going to write us back in?
What's going to happen?
So the last episode, my agent calls me and said, hey, they're bringing you back.
I was like, oh, my goodness.
So the last episode of season eight, they brought us back.
我说，嘿，伙计，我们可能不会回来了。所以我们中彩票后，就离开了。我当时一直在看《办公室》的剧集。我当时就想，哦，天哪，他们会把我们写回剧情里吗？会发生什么？所以在最后一集，我的经纪人打电话给我，说，嘿，他们要让你回来了。我当时想，哦，天哪。所以在第八季的最后一集，他们把我们带了回来。
And that's where that scene came from.
I was like, thank you.
That scene is so great.
I want you to know, I went down the rabbit hole looking for bloopers.
I was positive that there was a blooper from that scene.
I actually really want to reach out to Dave Rogers and be like, I know you guys look like you're about to lose it.
But if I find that blooper, I'm going to send it to you.
Yeah, he day is so funny.
那个场景就是这么来的。我说，谢谢你。那个场景太棒了。我想让你知道，我为了找花絮，把能翻的都翻遍了。我当时确信那个场景肯定有花絮。我其实真的很想联系戴夫·罗杰斯，对他说，我知道你们当时看起来快要笑场了。但如果我找到那个花絮，我一定会发给你。是的，海代太搞笑了。
And we're still friends to this day as well.
So, yeah, He Day is a good friend of mine.
I had such a fun time hanging out with you guys at the office fan convention.
Yes.
And just catching up.
And he is the sweetest.
Yes.
The sweetest guy.
而且直到今天我们还是好朋友。所以，是的，海代是我的好朋友。我在《办公室》粉丝见面会上和你们一起玩得非常开心。没错。就是叙叙旧。而且他最甜了。是的，最甜的人。
He is.
And I have a question sort of in that vein.
How has being on the office changed your life?
Because you're going to these fan conventions now.
You must get recognized.
Correct.
Funny story.
他是。我有关于这方面的一个问题。参演《办公室》是如何改变你的生活的？因为你现在要去参加这些粉丝见面会。你一定会被人认出来。没错，没错。有个有趣的故事。
Before I cut my hair and all of that stuff, I get recognized a lot.
But now my twin brother gets recognized as me on the office because he's, he's, he's, he's,
still looks like that. Yes. So it's amazing. And when he's out and about and he calls me up and he said,
hey, or he'll text me first. Can I FaceTime you? Someone wants to say hi. They thought all was you.
So I want to introduce him to the real you. But he was also on an episode. Yes, the Matrix,
the Matrix. So Jam is pranking Dwight so that Dwight thinks he's in the Matrix. Correct.
And so the glitch in the Matrix where you see the like carbon footprint of yourself and you know there's a
glitch, you know, like how the cat crosses the road twice. It's you and your twin are the glitch
在我剪头发以及做那些改变之前，我经常被人认出来。但现在我的双胞胎兄弟在《办公室》里被认成是我，因为他、他、他、他看起来还是那个样子。是的。所以这太神奇了。当他出门在外给我打电话，他会对我说，嘿，或者他会先发短信给我。我能跟你视频通话吗？有人想打个招呼。他们以为一直都是你。所以我想把他介绍给真实的你。但他其实也客串过一集。没错，《黑客帝国》，《黑客帝国》。所以杰姆在捉弄德怀特，让德怀特以为自己身处《黑客帝国》中。没错。所以在《黑客帝国》里那个故障片段中，你看到了你自己的碳足迹，你知道出了故障，就像猫两次穿过马路一样。你和你的双胞胎兄弟就是那个故障
and the matrix. Correct. That's amazing. Well, so when people run into him and ask him fees on
the office, he's like, technically yes, but I think the person you want to talk to is my brother.
Correct. Yeah. It's funny. To me, it's funny and so great at the same time. Yeah. The office is like
one of them shows that most people wish they were a part of. I mean, I didn't know what I was getting
into. I'm pretty sure you ladies didn't either. Oh, no way. So this thing is like, it's still out there
just making new fans. You know, it's pretty wild, right? Correct. Yeah. And the people that love it
know it so well. They will know that your character had three names. Like, they know all those details,
you know? Correct. Correct. I mean, there was a woman at the convention, and she has the Holy Grail tattooed
和黑客帝国。没错。太神奇了。所以当人们遇到他并问他是不是演过《办公室》时，他会说，严格来说是的，但我觉得你想找的人是我兄弟。没错。是的。这很有趣。对我来说，既有趣又棒极了。是的。《黑客帝国》是一部大多数人都希望能参与其中的剧集。我的意思是，我当时并不知道自己要面对什么。我敢肯定你们女士们也不知道。哦，绝对不知道。所以这东西就像是，它现在依然存在，还在吸引新粉丝。你知道，这挺疯狂的，对吧？没错。是的。而且热爱它的人对它了如指掌。他们会知道你的角色有三个名字。比如，他们知道所有这些细节，你知道的？没错，没错。我的意思是，见面会上有一位女士，她把圣杯纹在了
on her calf. Oh, yeah. That is crazy. That you know. So I was like, that you know,
You dip your donut into your character?
Correct.
Oh, my gosh.
Wow.
She was like, I want to show you something.
So she has Michael Scott tattooed on her arm or something like that.
So she has everyone tattooed on her body.
小腿上。哦，是的。太疯狂了。你懂的。所以我当时想，你懂的。你把甜甜圈蘸到你的角色里？克里，天哪。哇。她说，我想给你看个东西。所以她把迈克尔·斯科特的头像纹在了胳膊上诸如此类的地方。所以她把所有人都纹在了身上。
And I was like, oh, my God.
So the fans are amazing.
They are.
They are a wonderful community.
I'm so thankful for them.
I am so curious.
We ask anyone, you know, that we've had on here that's been on the office,
if they had a favorite scene or episode or just what is your fan moment from being on the office, the episode you love?
我当时想，哦，天哪。所以粉丝们太棒了。他们真的是。他们是一个 maravilhoso 的社群。我非常感谢他们。我真的很好奇。我们问过任何来过这里、参演过《办公室》的人，问他们有没有最喜欢的场景或剧集，或者你在《办公室》里最棒的粉丝时刻是什么，你最喜欢哪一集？
Oh, man, it's so many.
I know.
It's hard, right?
We get asked this question all the time.
You know what?
I love all your episodes with Rain, the interaction between you guys.
It's so comical.
And your love story with Jim, it's like, couldn't get any better than that, you know?
哦，天哪，太多了。我知道。很难选，对吧？大家总是问我们这个问题。你知道吗？我喜欢你和雷恩的所有对手戏，你们之间的互动太滑稽了。你和杰姆的爱情故事，简直不能再美好了，你知道吗？
Like I said, I was just the person in the back field watching you guys.
work. So every part of that show I love, you know, there's not just one episode that I loved. I loved
at all. I'm like, let's go back and do it again. Not to shoot what we already shot. Let's go back and
do it again. You know what I mean? It would be really cool. You know, we've talked about that.
If we could go back to one episode or one moment and do it again. And I feel like we always say like just a
one big ensemble scene where we're all together.
Yeah.
You know, I was watching weight loss where we're all in the warehouse and we're all standing
就像我说的，我只是在后景里看着你们工作。所以我喜欢这部剧的每一个部分，你知道，没有哪一集是我特别最喜欢的。我全都喜欢。我甚至想说，让我们回去再拍一次吧。不是说重新拍我们已经拍过的内容。让我们回去再重新体验一次。你知道我的意思吗？那真的很酷。你知道，我们讨论过这个。如果我们能回到某集或某个时刻再拍一次。我觉得我们总是会说，就像那种我们都在一起的大型群戏。是的。你知道，我看减肥那一集的时候，我们都在仓库里，我们都站在
on that and like Andy sort of like spits.
Thinks he's going to lose weight by spitting and you give him such a like, oh my God,
terrifying like scary look.
But we were all in this little, you know, room or we'd be in a conference room scene.
Those kind of moments where we were all together was really special moments.
Yes.
It was all special, yes.
Well, before we let you go, is there anything about your time on the office that you haven't shared with us?
那个上面，安迪好像吐了一口唾沫。以为通过吐口水能减肥，然后你给了他一个那种，哦，天哪，极其可怕的令人害怕的眼神。但我们都在这个小房间里，或者我们在会议室的场景里。那种我们都在一起的时刻，真的是非常特别的时刻。是的，全都很特别，是的。好吧，在我们让你离开之前，关于你在《办公室》的时光，有什么事是你还没跟我们分享过的吗？
Any behind-the-scenes stories or memories?
We spent so much time on that show.
I think every moment that I spent on the show was a great memory for me.
There's not one that stood out because I was just so excited to get there.
Yeah.
You know, whenever I was working just to see you all, you know, and be a part of it.
So, yeah, just being there, every time I had a chance to be there was a great memory for me.
Yeah.
有什么幕后故事或回忆吗？我们在那部剧上花了那么多时间。我觉得我在那部剧里度过的每一刻对我来说都是美好的回忆。没有什么特别突出的，因为我当时只是太兴奋能去那里了。是的。你知道，每当我工作时，只要能见到你们大家，并成为其中的一部分。所以，是的，只要能在那里，我每一次有机会去那里的经历对我来说都是美好的回忆。是的。
It was great people, great food.
Always great food.
Great comedy.
But also, like, how crazy is it that this thing that we did so long ago, it's still being watched?
It's still beloved.
And, you know, it's endured.
You're part of that.
You know, you're part of this wonderful thing.
那是很棒的人，很棒的食物。总是有很棒的食物。很棒的喜剧。但同时，也是，我们很久以前做的这件事情，现在依然在被人观看，这难道不疯狂吗？它依然深受喜爱。而且，你知道，它经久不衰。你也是其中的一部分。你知道，你是这个美好事物的一部分。
I tell some of my family members, I'm like, it's the gift that keeps giving because it's not going anywhere.
It's right there in front of your face.
If you turn on the TV, it's right there.
You don't really have to search that hard for it.
Just go through the channels, the office.
Yeah.
Office.
Oh, my gosh.
我告诉我的某些家庭成员，我说，这是源源不断的礼物，因为它哪儿也没去。它就在你眼前。如果你打开电视，它就在那儿。你其实不需要费多大劲去寻找它。只要换换频道，《办公室》。是的，《办公室》。哦，天哪。
Have you been on a plane and watched someone watch the office?
I have.
Yeah.
And a part of me want to say, hey, I was in that.
They totally love it.
I have yet to see someone watch an episode I was on, but I've seen people watch it, you know.
你有没有在飞机上看到别人在看《办公室》？我有。我有。我有。是的。而且我有一部分内心想要说，嘿，我也演了那个。他们真的超爱看。我还没见过有人看我演的那一集，但我见过人们看它，你知道的。
So that's amazing.
And what does your family think?
Are you the first actor in the family, the first person to work in the entertainment industry?
Yes.
So what is that like for that?
My mom thinks it's hilarious.
Okay.
You know, she's like, so what are you working on now?
所以这太神奇了。你家人怎么看？你是家里第一个演员，第一个进入娱乐行业的人吗？是的。所以这对他们来说是怎样的体验？我妈妈觉得这太搞笑了。好的。你知道，她会说，那你现在在做什么？
Like, what are you doing today?
Like, so.
And she knows, like, I'm always on set doing.
something because I'm pretty sure you all already know me.
Well, my wife owns, she owns House of Talent, a commercial casting company, TV and film,
stuff like that.
And we're always on set.
So it's amazing.
就像，你今天在做什么？类似这样。她知道，我总是待在片场做点什么，因为我敢肯定你们大家都已经了解我了。嗯，我妻子拥有，她拥有“明星之家”，一家商业选角公司，涉及电视和电影之类的东西。我们总是待在片场。所以这太神奇了。
You know, I have to say something, all those years we were working together, and we'd be
on the set, and sometimes there'd be really long shoot days, especially for some reason
when we were in the warehouse in particular, I feel like there were really big plot lines or
big stories over there. Well, it was very cavernous. And so they would spend more time figuring out
where to put the cameras sometimes because it was a very big space. Very big space. So we did,
there was a lot of coverage down there. And my memory of you on those long days is just looking
over at you and you would always have the biggest smile on your face. Like zero complaints,
so happy to be here. It's, whenever you feel welcome, you're happy.
你知道，我必须说，我们一起工作的那些年，我们在片场，有时拍摄时间真的很长，特别是不知道为什么当我们在仓库里的时候，我觉得那里有非常宏大的情节线或者宏大的故事。嗯，因为那是挑高的空间。所以他们有时会花更多时间来确定把摄像机放在哪里，因为那是一个非常大的空间。非常大的空间。所以我们在那里拍了很多远景。我对你在那些漫长日子里的记忆就是看着你，你的脸上总是挂着最灿烂的笑容。就像零抱怨，超级高兴能来到这里。这，每当你觉得受到欢迎时，你就会很高兴。
So you guys welcome me into a family.
And I was like, oh, man, okay, all right.
So that's all I can do is smile and be happy and appreciate it, you know.
So I appreciate my time on that show and everything I've done after that.
So I appreciate all of it because every day is a great day.
You know, there's no bad days, at least in my book, you know.
Oh, my gosh, Calvin, we need more of you in this world.
I'm telling you right now.
所以你们把我当成家人一样欢迎。我当时想，哦，天哪，好吧，好的。所以我能做的就是微笑、保持快乐并对此心存感激，你知道的。所以我感激我在那部剧里的时光以及之后我所做的一切。所以我对此心存感激，因为每一天都是美好的一天。你知道，至少在我看来，没有糟糕的日子，你知道的。哦，天哪，卡尔文，我们需要世界上有更多像你这样的人。我现在就这么告诉你。
Oh, well, thank you for coming in today.
Come on, Calvin.
You just absolute ray of sunshine of a human.
Thanks so much for being here.
Thank you, ladies, for having me.
It's been a pleasure.
We're still friends.
Yeah.
哦，好吧，谢谢你今天能来。拜托，卡尔文。你简直是人类的一束阳光。非常感谢你能来到这里。谢谢你们邀请我，女士们。这真是我的荣幸。我们还是朋友。是的。
It's crazy.
Well, thank you so much.
Stay in touch.
We love you.
Love you.
Love you both.
太疯狂了。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。好吧，非常感谢。保持联系。我们爱你。爱你。你们俩我都爱。
Well, how delightful was that?
Love him.
I know.
He's just good people.
It's like seeing.
like your cousin. You're like, oh my God, how are you? It really is true. It's that office family is forever.
And every time any of us see each other, it's just a joyous occasion. Yeah. All right. Well,
should we get to a little Around the Town lady? Let's do it. Our first Around the Town is from
哇，那太令人愉快了？爱他。我知道。他真是个好人。这就像看到你的表亲。你会想，哦，天哪，你好吗？这真的是真的。《办公室》这个大家庭永远都在。我们每次见到彼此，都只是一场欢乐的聚会。是的。好吧，那么，我们要不要来点“小镇周围”的栏目呢？开始吧。我们的第一个“小镇周围”来自
Alexandra L and Coraville, Iowa. Alexandra said every May, the town holds a citywide garage sale weekend,
followed by a swap weekend where everyone can bring their unwanted stuff to the City Hall parking lot
and take whatever they want for free.
Items not claimed are donated to a nonprofit.
After that comes Mayors Cleanup Week where everyone puts the remaining unwanted items on the curb for trash pickup.
People all over town then drive around and pick out treasures before the trash pickup happens.
It's amazing what you can find in good shape.
We always enjoy searching for treasures three weeks in a row.
艾略特·L，来自爱荷华州科勒维尔。艾莉克莎说，每年五月，镇上都会举办全市范围的车库大卖场周末，随后是一个交换周末，每个人都可以把自己不需要的东西带到市政厅停车场，免费拿走任何自己想要的东西。没有被认领的物品会被捐赠给非营利组织。接下来是市长清洁周，每个人都会把剩下不需要的东西放在路边等待垃圾清运。全镇的人都会开车四处转转，在垃圾被运走之前挑选出各种“宝贝”。你能找到品相完好的东西，这真是太神奇了。我们总是连续三个星期乐此不疲地寻宝。
We've ended up with a play set, kitty pool, cat tree, patio set, tons of kids' clothes, and so much else from these events.
I've never lived anywhere so dedicated to reusing unwanted items.
How fantastic is that?
The whole town is spring cleaning at the same time.
I love it.
It's so smart.
I love a garage sale.
我们最终从这些活动中搞到了一套儿童滑梯、一个儿童游泳池、一个猫爬架、一套露台桌椅、大量的童装以及其他许许多多东西。我从没住过哪个地方这么热衷于循环利用闲置物品。这简直太棒了不是吗？全镇都在同时进行春大扫除。我太喜欢了。这太聪明了。这太聪明了。我太喜欢车库旧货出售了。
I love everything about this.
And then the swap and then the things for free.
Come on.
I got very worked up about that one.
Sorry, I was very excited.
It's very cool.
All right, mine is from Margaret C.
and Masselin, Ohio, who said,
我爱极了这一切。还有随后的物品交换和免费赠送活动。真是绝了。我刚才对那个激动得不行。抱歉，我刚才太兴奋了。这真的很酷。好啦，我的这条留言来自俄亥俄州马西隆的玛格丽特·C，她说，
our thriving, quote, city of champions
of 32,000 Massalonians is celebrating its 200th birthday this year.
Massalind's history includes providing a safe haven
of the Underground Railroad,
being a historic shipping town on the Ohio and Erie Canal,
and later a hub for steel and heavy industry.
Some of our towns, many noted citizens, include silent film stars Lillian and Dorothy Gish,
Browns and Bengals coach Paul Brown, and actors David Canary, Yvette Nicole Brown, and Matt Lanter,
我们这座繁荣的、号称拥有三万两千名居民的“冠军之城”马西隆，今年正在庆祝它的两百岁生日。马西隆的历史包括：曾为地下铁路提供安全庇护所，是俄亥俄与伊利运河上历史悠久的航运镇，后来成为钢铁和重工业的中心。我们镇上的许多知名公民包括：无声电影明星莉莲和多萝西·吉什、布朗队及孟加拉虎队教练保罗·布朗，以及演员大卫·卡纳里、伊维特·妮可·布朗和马特·兰特尔，
and singer Jeff Timmons.
Our Masselin Tigers High School football team also has an elite history with 25 state championships.
We are really so proud of our Northeast Ohio City and invite everyone to celebrate at our many patriotic events,
this year. Massland, Ohio is crushing it. Happy birthday. Happy birthday. 25 state wins. What?
Well done. Our next one is from Sam C. in Gainesville, Florida. Sam says, at age 21, I just released
my first album. I make music under the name Sam Cone. So to celebrate, I threw a cone-themed
listening party. My friends and I snacked on pop cone, conola, ice cream cones, chips con queso, and
bugles. Oh, because bugles are in the shape of a cone lady. While we listened to the album titled
还有歌手杰夫·蒂蒙斯。我们马西隆老虎高中橄榄球队也有着辉煌的历史，曾获得25次州冠军。我们真的为这座俄亥俄州东北部的城市感到无比自豪，并邀请大家今年来参加我们的许多爱国庆祝活动。俄亥俄州马西隆简直太棒了。生日快乐。生日快乐。25次州冠军？真的吗？太厉害了。我们的下一条留言来自佛罗里达州盖恩斯维尔的萨姆·C。萨姆说，在21岁时，我刚刚发行了我的第一张专辑。我以萨姆·科恩的名字创作音乐。为了庆祝，我办了一场以“圆锥筒（Cone）”为主题的试听派对。我和朋友们吃了爆米花、卡诺拉油炸小吃、冰淇淋甜筒、奶酪玉米角和牛角脆。哦，因为牛角脆是圆锥形的呀，女士。当我们聆听专辑时，专辑的名字叫作
Whist Away, drinks included vodka cone berries and pina cone ladas. We had a blast. Oh, Sam,
congratulations. Yeah. At 21? 21, Sam Cone. Way to go. Wow. I don't know what I was doing
at 21, but I hadn't just finished a whole album, I'll tell you that.
I know where I was when I turned 21.
Had you finished something like an album?
I was writing a term paper at my desk, and I didn't go out and celebrate, but I did go to
the gas station.
My dad had given me a gas card just for gas, but I would buy groceries on it.
《Whist Away》，饮品包括伏特加蔓越莓冰沙和椰林飘香冰沙。我们玩得开心极了。哦，萨姆，祝贺你。是的。21岁？21岁的萨姆·科恩。真有一套。哇。我不知道我21岁时在干什么，但我当时可没刚完成整整一张专辑，我得这么说。我知道我21岁生日那天在哪里。你当时完成类似专辑的东西了吗？我当时正坐在书桌前写学期论文，我没有出去庆祝，但我去了加油站。我爸爸给了我一张只能用来加油的油卡，但我用它买了一些杂货。
And I went in proudly, and I bought myself a Coronita, which is a mini bottle of beer.
to celebrate your 21st birthday because you were in the middle of a term paper.
Yes.
But it wasn't an album, Sam Cohn.
It was just a term paper.
Well, let's move on to our office question of the week.
Yeah, this one is coming from Ella M in Louisiana who says,
Hi, Office Ladies.
然后我昂首阔步地走进去，给自己买了一瓶科罗娜小啤酒，用来庆祝你的21岁生日，因为你当时正忙着写学期论文？是的。但那可不是一张专辑，萨姆·科恩。那只是一篇学期论文。好吧，让我们进入本周的办公室问题。是的，这个问题来自路易斯安那州的艾拉·M，她说，嗨，办公室女士们。
Do you have a favorite show with a similar vibe as The Office?
What other shows should Office fans watch?
Well, my family just did a rewatch of Modern Family.
which has that same sort of like cutting away to talking heads to like interview segments.
I think the comedy is really good.
I would recommend that.
But you know what they don't do like we do is break the fourth wall.
So there's none of that looking to camera.
你们有没有哪部最喜欢的剧集，氛围和《办公室》类似？《办公室》的粉丝们还应该看什么其他剧集？嗯，我的家人最近重温了《摩登家庭》，它也有那种切到主角进行单人访谈的镜头。我觉得喜剧效果真的很棒。我会推荐这部。但你们知道他们没有做的是打破第四堵墙。所以没有那种直视镜头的桥段。
It's not documentary style, but it's sort of documentary style.
But I think that's pretty close.
Yeah.
I mean, this is a great question.
I really liked it.
So I was thinking, you know, my family and I are watching.
right now. It's the first time for the kids seeing it, but we're watching Arrested Development.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. And it's got that very single camera. You kind of feel like you're watching,
它虽然不是纪录片风格，但有点像纪录片风格。不过我觉得这已经相当接近了。对啊。我的意思是，这是一个很好的问题。我真的很喜欢。所以我在想，你知道，我和我的家人现在正在看这部剧。这是孩子们第一次看，但我们在看《发展受阻》。哦，对。是的。它采用了单机拍摄。你会觉得自己好像在看，
like getting the people inside some family's life. Yeah. It's very quirky. It's very funny.
And then I was always a fan of Reno 9-1-1. Oh, that's a great answer. Yeah. Because that is very much in the same
style. And I think if I were thinking of like new shows, like shows today, I would say,
jury duty, written by Lee and Gene. For sure. So good. I would say St. Dennis Medical,
and Animal Control. Yeah. And also, you know, the show Superstore, created by Justin Spitzer.
Oh, yes. That similar vibe. It does. It's a good comedy. You know, for me, this idea of a fake
documentary TV show goes back to the Larry Sanders show. I loved that show. So good. And if you haven't seen it,
It's just fantastic.
就像是在窥探某个人一家的生活。是的。它非常古怪。非常搞笑。然后我一直都是《雷诺911》的粉丝。哦，那是个很好的回答。是的。因为那部剧的风格确实非常相似。而且我想如果我要想一些新剧，比如现在的剧，我会说是李和吉恩编剧的《陪审团义务》。肯定的。太棒了。我要说《圣丹尼斯医疗》和《动物管制》。是的。还有，你知道由贾斯汀·斯皮策创作的剧集《超级超市》。哦，是的。那种氛围很像。确实如此。这是一部很好的喜剧。对我来说，这种伪纪录片式的电视剧的想法可以追溯到《拉里·桑德斯秀》。我超爱那部剧。太棒了。如果你没看过，它简直绝了。
It's behind the scenes of a talk show.
Yeah, of a late night talk show.
In fact, the DP that shot the office pilot shot the Larry Sanders show.
He was just with us for that one episode, the pilot, Peter Smokler is his name.
But, you know, you're going to see that same kind of style.
But again, they don't break the fourth wall.
And they don't do talking heads.
It's more like caught on the fly documentary sort of thing.
那是关于一档脱口秀节目的幕后故事。是的，是一档深夜脱口秀节目。事实上，拍摄《办公室》试播集的摄影指导也拍摄了《拉里·桑德斯秀》。他只参与了我们那一集，也就是试播集，他叫彼得·斯莫克勒。但是，你会发现那种风格非常相似。不过话说回来，他们没有打破第四堵墙。他们也没有单人访谈。更像是一种偶然捕捉到的纪录片那样的风格。
You know what I was thinking about as far as breaking the fourth wall?
the fourth wall in a really, really cool, inventive way was fleabged.
Oh, yes.
Because the scene plays out and then she'll look straight to camera and have this aside.
Not to a documentary crew.
It's like her inner thoughts to herself.
Yes.
And then if I could give a shameless plug.
你们知道我在想关于打破第四堵墙的什么吗？以一种非常非常酷、极具创意的方式打破第四堵墙的是《伦敦生活》。哦，是的。因为场景正在进行，然后她会直视镜头并说出旁白。不是对纪录片摄制组说。就像是她对自己内心的独白。是的。然后如果我可以厚着脸皮宣传一下的话。
Oh, yeah, do it.
I have become a recurring character on the Chit Show, which is a group of Groundlings folks,
and it's a digital series, and it's so fun and funny.
and it's in an office and there's all the camera whips and there's breaking the fourth wall.
It's really taking me back.
Like, I love this group of people.
And it's just been my absolute pleasure.
I was so honored that they asked me.
哦，对，宣传一下吧。我成了《聊天秀》的常驻角色，这是一个由地面剧团（Groundlings）成员组成的团队推出的数字系列剧，真的非常有趣好笑。故事发生在一个办公室里，有很多镜头快速摇晃，还有打破第四堵墙的桥段。这真的让我梦回当年。我很喜欢这群人。这绝对是我的荣幸。他们邀请我时我感到非常荣幸。
I was so flattered that they asked me.
So I play Bitsy, who is the auditor from corporate, who's come down.
And so every once in a while I show up.
And no one likes, no one.
I'm real tough.
No one's happy to see an auditor, right?
No, no one.
And Bitsy's really grouchy because she has a rash that goes from her knee to her neck.
他们邀请我时我感到受宠若惊。所以我饰演比齐，她是来自总公司的审计员，来到分公司视察。所以我每隔一段时间就会出现。而且没人喜欢，真的没人喜欢。我可严厉了。没有人会高兴看到审计员对吧？对，没人喜欢。而且比齐脾气很暴躁，因为她从膝盖到脖子长了一处皮疹。
I love the name Bitsy, by the way.
She's having to deal with this rash all the time, and it just puts her in a, she's in a sour mood a lot.
Yeah.
Go check that out.
It's really fun to see Jenna in this role.
And Angela, you've got a plug before we go.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know.
顺便说一句，我很喜欢“比齐”这个名字。她不得不一直应对这个皮疹，这让她经常处于一种暴躁的心情中。是的。去看看吧。看詹娜扮演这个角色真的很有趣。安吉拉，在我们结束之前，你也有个要宣传的事吧。哦，天哪。我不知道算不算宣传。
It's not so much a plug.
It's just like, hey, if you guys are in Raleigh, North Carolina, July 25th through the 26,
Rain Wilson and I are going to be there at GalaxyCon.
And, you know, I love meeting office fans.
I love chatting with people.
So come say hi.
Well, there you have it, folks.
I think this was a fun episode.
与其说是宣传，不如说就像是，嘿，如果你们在7月25日到26日期间去到北卡罗来纳州罗利市，雷恩·威尔逊和我将会在那里参加银河动漫展。而且，你知道的，我喜欢结识《办公室》的粉丝。我喜欢和大家聊天。所以来打个招呼吧。好了，各位，就是这样。我觉得这是一期有趣的节目。
Yeah.
We set the record straight on some things.
We got to talk to Calvin.
We learned about this incredible, I kind of want to go next May to Iowa.
I know.
I mean, I'd like to see that.
Lady, you know I want a road trip with you.
I know.
是的。我们在某些事情上澄清了事实。我们和卡尔文聊了聊。我们了解到了这个不可思议的活动，我甚至有点想明年五月去一趟艾奥瓦州了。我知道。我是说，我也想去看看。女士，你知道我想和你一起自驾游的。我知道。
And a road trip to a garage.
with my best friend.
I know.
Get out.
I'm in.
All right, everybody.
Have a great week.
We'll see you next week.
而且要和我的最好朋友一起自驾去逛旧货店。我知道。太棒了。算我一个。好了，各位。祝大家有个愉快的一周。我们下周见。
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛公司的一档节目，由珍妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。奥德赛公司的执行制作人是利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。